the woman is even dumber than I thought
it must be because she has nothing else
to do this week my favorite ex
politician Hillary Clinton put out this
tweet quote I say this as a former
Secretary of State and as an American
the Russians are still coming our
intelligence professionals are imploring
Trump to act will he continue to ignore
and surrender or protect our country say
what Hillary the Russians are still
coming you're kidding right
did you fall asleep during this movie
you see that is how we got and Hillary
our intelligence professionals are
imploring Trump to act where did you get
that from you don't even have a security
clearance not that it mattered when you
did have one and by the way if you're
talking about NSA director Mike Rogers
he testified this week that our
government was taking steps to combat
Russian interference but probably not
enough which is a hell of a lot better
than opening up your emails like an
orchid like you did to every hacker out
there and when Muller indicted 13
Russians for interfering in the 2016
election a lot of the cases went back to
2014 and Obama simply failed to act
thinking as long as it benefited you
Hillary why interfere and if you're
worried about Putin bragging about
Russia's military might against the u.s.
keep in mind Hillary Putin's running for
office he's going to say whatever he
thinks is necessary to win no one should
understand that better than you remember
to just be grossly generalistic you
could put
half of Trump supporters into what I
call the basket of deplorable z-- right
the racist sexist homophobic xenophobic
Islamophobic you name it and
unfortunately there are people like that
and he has lifted them up and by the way
Putin himself wasn't much too happy with
you when you interfered in his election
you and the Democrats have used Russia
as an excuse for not winning the
Russians are fed up with us so Putin
unites his country by going after the
common enemy Hillary who do you think
you're kidding you're the one who did
the reset button with Russia you wanted
to make pals with them and your comrade
in arms Barack Obama had his famous
off-mike moment with Medvedev the
worsens had more access to our elections
when you were in power and your buddy
Obama when it came out that he knew
about the hacking and the possible
impact on the election when he was in a
position to do something about it by the
way he says he told Putin to cut it out
and when the russians hacked the DNC's
emails including yours exposing you as a
two-faced liar that you are you wouldn't
even cooperate with the FBI's
investigation and Hillary you asked if
Trump will continue to ignore and
surrender honey
ignoring and surrendering was when you
and Bill sold twenty percent of our
natural resource you rhenium to the
Russians with a payback of a hundred and
forty five million to your foundation
and five hundred thousand cash in your
hubby's pocket you surrendered one of
our most important natural resources
used to make Molly 99 the essential
element to nuclear medicine used to
diagnose and treat 45 million people a
year and you want to criticize Donald
Trump unlike you and Bill Donald Trump
can't be bought and you ask who the
president protect our country he's not
like your philandering husband
gave billions to kim jong un's father to
not build a nuclear weapon that worked
out really well now didn't it Donald
Trump is the only president with the
guts to not only send the mother of all
bombs into Afghanistan destroy chemical
weapon plants in Syria with surgical
precision but also go toe to toe with
Kim Jong on to the point where that
wackadoo has become a laughingstock
and unlike Obama who reduced our
military every chance he could Donald
Trump has committed seven hundred
million dollars to rebuild our armed
forces so that he can protect the
country that your husband and your
comrade Barack made more vulnerable so
if you're so convinced the Russians are
still coming why didn't you do something
about it when you were in office instead
of being the cash receptacle for every
corrupt Russian looking to bribe you and
make money in this country Hillary it's
got to be tough being you you used all
the money you illegally took from
foreign powers to create a false dossier
against Donald Trump you got fed debate
questions deleted 33,000 emails and yet
you still lost as someone you say isn't
fit to be President I got an idea honey
since you're so good at selling uranium
to foreigners and our enemies maybe you
can buddy up with your Clinton
Foundation friends to sell the rest of
our uranium to the Russians on second
thought just get back into the woods and
that's my open tell me what you think on
my Facebook page Twitter and Instagram
hashtag judge Janine